fue un debate convocado de urgencia para
escuchar el nuevo plan financiero por
parte del nuevo de ministro de finanzas
que lleva apenas dos días en el cargo y
que destrozó palabras más palabras menos
el plan financiero presentado por la
propia Hace tres semanas pero el debate
rápidamente se convirtió en una pregunta
en común Dónde está la primera ministra
ante semejante crisis política y
económica que afronta el país benimarden
que es la jefe del gobierno en la cámara
de los comunes asumió la defensa de
listas y dijo que la primera ministra
estaba atendiendo asuntos urgentes pero
nunca reveló cuáles eran estos y dijo
frases poco comunes en la cámara de los
comunes como que el disfraz no estaba
escondida debajo de su escritorio fue
tal la presión que la primera ministra
entró por unos minutos a la cámara de
los comunes estuvo prácticamente en
silencio nos dijo una la palabra en
público y estuvo casi que sin expresión
en su rostro entre tanto los laboristas
dijeron que listras no tiene autoridad
credibilidad y no tiene poder que está
en el cargo pero no tiene poder y dijo
que quien creó el caos no puede quedar a
resolverlo justamente con este panorama
como se ve el futuro político de la
primera ministra
lisstras Está tratando de sobrevivir en
este momento porque sabe que tiene
amenazado su gobierno está prácticamente
en la puerta de downing Street a 40 días
que lleva en el cargo ya no tiene ni
incredibilidad ni autoridad ni su
capital político está completamente
quemado para tratar de sobrevivir a esta
crisis listradas y sus aliados políticos
se reúnen esta noche con integrantes del
partido conservador para tratar de
frenar esas conspiraciones que la
quieren fuera y es que algunos diputados
conservadores en público pero
especialmente en privado están empezando
a ajustar las fichas para que entonces
esa inmunidad que tiene listas por un
año como primera ministra sea modificada
y entonces pueda convocarse a una moción
de confianza para que listras pueda ser
removida también se habla que la primera
ministra ha tenido reuniones
regulares con el jefe del poderoso
comité
1922 que se encarga justamente de eso de
poder dejar o sacar un Primer Ministro